[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vêtu de l'uniforme de rigur dans les
centres nucléaires le général de Gaulle
a commencé son 20e voyage en France par
Pierre lat et kadarach qui seront demain
les deux pièces maîtresses de
l'industrie atomique française il a
voulu également au cours de ce voyage
aller s'incliner sur ce plateau du
vercore que la résistance des maizars en
1944 fit entrer dans l'histoire au prix
de 750
[Musique]
martis par Orange Avignon Carpentra
pendant les 4 jours de ce voyage
nombreux étaient les Français qui
avaient tenu à saluer à son passage le
président de la
République dans chacune de ces
allocution le chef de l'État a développé
surtout les raisons qui poussent la
France à jouer son rôle personnel au
milieu des nations et entre les deux
colos qui détiennent la force les
Français a-til dit ont le droit de
penser être les meilleurs juges de ce
qu'ils ont à faire et qu'ils n'ont à
laisser à personne le droit d'agir ou de
parler pour
eux 1500 ans d'histoire
nous ont appris qu'être la
France cela ne va pas sans
difficulté sans risques et sans frais
mais autant que
jamais nous tenons à l'indépendance
ouvert voici bientôt 1 an par jean2 le
Concil écuménique Vatican 2 a repris ses
travaux après 9 mois d'interruption
9 mois au cours desquel cardinal Montini
est devenu le pape Paul VI autour du
nouveau souverain pontif voici de
nouveau réuni l'immense assemblée de
l'église en ouvrant solennellement cette
deuxè session Paul 6 en a défini l'objet
veiller au renouveau de l'Église ouvrir
le dialogue avec les églises séparées
jeter à un pont vers le monde
[Musique]
d'aujourd'hui chaque époque a ses héros
la nôtre à Gagarine le premier homme qui
est jamais tourné dans les passe autour
de la Terre est venu passer quelques
jours à Paris où la population lui a
réservé un accueil enthousiaste il y a
eu d'autres cosmonautes mais Gagarine
fut le premier et son nom reste attaché
au début de l'ère cosmique c'est à ce
titre qu'il devait être la vedette au
palais de l'UNESCO du 24e congrès
international d'astronautique le 24e
déjà où 1000 spécialistes ont évoqué les
nouvelles étapes de la conquête de
l'espace et yri Gagarine ajoutera à ses
nombreux trophées le prix galaber
d'astronautique pour son vol orbital
d'avril 61 il n'y a pas 3
[Musique]
ans sans aucun doute il se porte bien
très bien même témoin celui-ci qui
chante avec le même succès depuis
quelques 30
[Musique]
ans beaujours
oui oui oui
temp des
Guitar le temps des
f vous l'avez reconnu c'est bientinossi
celui-là même un peu plus mince sans
doute qui chantait
[Musique]
Catari
c'était l'époque du célèbre film Naple
au baiser de feu où tinorossi tenait
déjà sous son charme tout un public
féminin un public où se retrouvaient
toutes les classes et toutes les
générations et dont l'admiration émue
devait l'accompagner pendant un quart de
siècle quelle femme depuis cette époque
n'a pas frémi lorsque slevait la
vocaliste
célèbre d'ajio tinorossi entre son
épouse et son fils peut dire qu'il est
au monde le chanteur dont le plus grand
nombre de disques a reproduit la voix et
qu'il est resté pour le public une idole
dont le prestige est demeuré
[Musique]
intâ c'est la raison pour laquelle les
visites sont nombreuses à la Villa Le
Scudo où se rencontrent aussi bien des
compositeurs de Paris que les
guitaristes de l'île de beauté et l'on
sait que la guitare a joué un certain
rôle dans la vie de
[Musique]
n 28 ans après Marinella tinorossi se
retrouve sur les planches à l'heure du
twist mais ce sera un twist de
charme je l'ai chanté depuis
toujours je l'ai
chanté depuis
[Applaudissements]
toujours
en venant inaugurer la 3è Bienale de
Paris monsieur André Maler ministre des
Affaires Culturelles avait rendez-vous
avec ce que l'on pourrait nommer la
nouvelle vague de l'art un art qui
surprend sans doute mais qu'il convient
aussi de considérer d'un œil
neuf plus de 1000 exposants de moins de
35 ans représentant 58 pays nous
entraînent ASI de réalité nouvelle en
réalité nouvelle du métro dévoreur
d'homme au soufflet qui permet
d'apprécier dans les conditions optima
l'œuvre qui
[Musique]
l'anime un regard sur l'antimchine la
machine parfaitement inutile et il ne
sera plus possible de nier l'existence
d'un art nouveau aux formes multiples
suscité par le rythme de plus en plus
rapide de notre époque rêvons
[Musique]
rêvons aussi Messieurs d'élégance
fonctionnelle pour les sportifs en effet
l'élégance doit être adapté et pratique
et ce costume à gilet sans manange fera
le bonheur des automobilistes une mode
créée par des sportifs pour des sportifs
tel est le mot d'ordre lancé par
l'association de propagande du vêtement
masculin devant un aréopage d'as du
volant et du ballon rond Louis Finot
ancienne international de football a
même joué les mannequins quatre boutons
et petit revers la ville Bruno Bini un
autre international a fait ses premiers
pas sur le podium en présentant sa veste
à poche
verticale quant à Marcel qui fut
capitaine de l'équipe de France il a
préféré la veste classique mais
comportant des coudes renforcé
de mais on s'intéressera tout
spécialement au par-dessus cap conçu
sans Man pour laisser à l'automobiliste
toutes les du geste avec un souvenir ému
du temps des
[Musique]
fiacres
une fois de plus l'équipe de France de
football maillot foncé culotte blanche a
manqué sa rentrée internationale il est
vrai qu'elle rencontra à sopia en match
all des quart de finale de la Coupe
d'Europe des Nation sa bête noire la
Bulgarie depuis des années les Bulgares
se dressent toujours avec succès sur le
chemin des
Fran la tradition est encore respectée
malgré les prou du gardien de but
Bernard et les exploits techniques du
capitainevs des balles qui auraient pu
faire mouche l'équipe de France en a eu
quelques-unes comme celle-ci par exemple
mais quand le destin n'apporte pas son
petit coup de pouce à une équipe rien à
faire pour gagner et les Bulgares ont
encore battu la France par un but à Z0
c'est la coutume mais la revanche à
Paris c'est aussi une coutume alors les
Français sont quand même
optimistes c'est une amie que Paris
vient d'accueillir en la personne de la
grande du Charlotte de Luxembourg son
premier geste fut de se recueillir en
compagnie du général de Gaulle sur le
tombeau du soldat
[Musique]
incognu bien des liens historiques
unissent les deux pays dans
l'édification de l'Europe le Luxembourg
qui abrita la première communauté
européenne celle du charbon et de
l'acier a joué un rôle éminemment
actif votre invitation a pu dire la
Grande Duchesse au chef de l'État est un
grand geste qui reconnaît au Luxembourg
sa place en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Europe pékin vient de célébrer le 14e
anniversaire de la République populaire
chinoise pour la 4e fois la grande
parade d'octobre ne comportait pas
d'autres évocations militaires que les
mitraillettes des miliciennes et les
bazookas des
[Musique]
miliciens dans la tribune officielle où
avait pris place
mauen et les leaders chinois on noté
l'absence des
Russes c'est au milieu d'une débauche de
fleurs et de banderol qu'un demiillion
de personnes ainsi défilé devant la
porte de la paix
[Applaudissements]
céleste au Sud Vietnam sur lequel se
sont concentrés depuis quelques temps
les feux de l'actualité internationale
les électeurs ont voté pour désigner les
123 nouveaux députés de l'Assemblée
nationale à Saigon où l'on évaluait la
participation électorale à 85 % le
président Diem est allé aux urnes
confiant la nouvelle Assemblée contra du
reste dans ses rangs sa jolie et B
madame qui effectue une tournée de
propagande en faveur du régime di et que
à Paris les tomates et les P de peinture
de quelques manifestant on laissé de
glace madame d'ailleurs n'est pas femme
je suis la cible favorite de cette
campagne car j'ai décidé de ne pas me
laisser intimider mais au contraire de
la dénoncer je n'ai jamais dit non plus
que les jeunes officiers américains au
Vietnam sont des soldats de fortuneant
rier et saboteur me juger sur je ne sais
quel rapport serait injuste cruel
incompréhensible choquant et extrêmement
offensant surtout quand toutes mes
conférences de presse sont enregistrées
vous le
voyez l'Indonésie pour tous c'est Bali
borneéo Sumatra Java et leurs images
aimables et pittoresques comme toujours
la réalité est différente l'Indonésie
c'est 100 millions d'habitants qui
essayent de vivre plus ou moins bien sur
1300 îles dont la surface égale qu fois
la
France c'est le pays de la mousson
c'est-à-dire 6 mois d'inondation qui
ravage les risières et 6 mois de
sécheresse où plus rien ne pousse pour
vivre mieux l'Indonésie de la vie sans
souci et des bains sans façon a grand
besoin d'accroître son potentiel
industriel et agricole ainsi est né le
projet du barrage de jatilure qui sera
le plus grand du monde et pour lequel le
gouvernement indonési fait appel à des
techniciens français équipé de turbines
produisant 700 millions de kWh par an il
sera en même temps un grand barrage de
retenu d'une capacité de 3 milliards de
mètres cubes qui serviront à
l'irrigation on attend de ces travaux
qui occupent 7000 ouvriers indonésien
sous la conduite d'ingénieur français
une récolte de riz supplémentaire par an
aux images d'une Indonésie
conventionnelle se substitue aujourd'hui
celle de l'Indonésie des réalités de
demain
un siècle a passé depuis qu'un belge de
Paris Étienne le noir créa la première
voiture dont le moteur dent brveté
utilisait un mélange détonnant à base de
vapeur de
pétrole l'allumage était provoqué par
une étincelle électrique éclatante entre
deux fils de
platine et ça
marchait Alphonse be de Rochas
perfectional l'invention il e l'idée de
comprimer le mélange d'étonnant avant de
l'enflammer édifiant ainsi la théorie du
moteur à quatre temps mais il fallut
attendre 26 ans pour que les Allemands
demler et mebac utilisent ces théories
pour créer le moteur à quatre temps et
ce furent deux firmes françaises qui
achetèrent à demler le brevet de son
moteur et c'est ainsi que d'une part
messieurs panard et levassur mirent au
point dans leurs usines d'iver à Paris
la première automobile à moteur à quatre
temps tandis que d'autre part on en
faisait autant chez Peugeot c'était en
[Musique]
1891 les voitures électriques ou les
voitures à vapeur représenté par les de
Dion Bouton et les ser poolis étaient
condamné on le vit bien lors des grandes
compétitions sur route que s'adjugèrent
très vite les voitures à
pétrole en 1900 la France berceau de
cette industrie comptait déjà
2997 véhicules en circulation en 1901
5386 en 1913 108000 temps lointains dont
les images nous arrachent un sourire
d'attendrissement avec leurs pot de Bic
leur cachpoussière et leur
voilettes le premier code de la route il
convient de le signaler naquit en
1899 il portait la signature du
président Émile
Loubet cette ambiance d'une époque
révolue le tout Paris a pu s'y plonger à
l'occasion du 50e salon de l'OTO car
c'est à la fois aux fans de l'automobile
d'aujourd'hui et d'hier que c'est ouvert
sur les Champs-Élysées le pub Renault
4000 personnes y ont fait un pèlerinage
au temps héroïques en compagnie de
Monsieur drefus président directeur
général de la régie d' montant de
reshuga Robinson et de Maurice
Chevalier mais au 50e salon 100 ans
après l'invention de le noir ce ne sont
pas les souvenirs du passé qui est venu
chercher la foule innombrable des
conducteurs et candidat conducteur
d'aujourd'hui une vision des voitures de
demain peut-être aux formes
vertigineuses un aperçu sur le nouveau
moteur rotatif version révolutionnaire
de notre quatre temps
[Musique]
éprouvé avant tout c'est aux voitures de
grande série que la foule a porté son
attention faire chez Peugeot par exemple
la connaissance du nouveau villebrequin
à 5 paliers qui équipe la
404 encore une fois la dernière née des
usines de Soo et vérifier la plus grande
habitabilité des places arrières
[Musique]
ou encore apprécier le confort de la
berline équipé du nouveau moteur diesel
1948 cm C on ne négligera pas de jeter
un regard attentif au pneumatique
élément important de la sécurité dont
les derniers neés se prévalent de leur
longue
durée
onéciera R8 Renault équipe aujourd'hui
la dauphine de frein à disque et de
boîte automatique on surveillera le
détail car on est devenu difficile
depuis le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
noir pour ces dizaines de milliers de
Parisiens long champ avec le Prix de
l'Arc de Triomphe c'est le rendez-vous
de la fortune pour des millions d'autres
Français installés devant leur poste de
radio ou de télévision c'est l'énorme
suspense au bout duquel vont pleuvoir à
gogo les millions de la Loterie
Nationale bref les 15 chevaux du Grand
Prix ont entamé à toute bride le Galot
de l'espoir un seul d'entre eux a droit
au triomphe un triomphe doré sur tranche
près de 1663 pour le gagnant que voici
et qui se dégage dès le début de la
dernière ligne droite
xby fonce il fonce vers la gloire et
vers la fortune xburry est bien
décidément le meilleur cheval européen
de la
[Musique]
saison de montagnes qui se détachent qui
s'écroule dans le lac artificiel créé
par le barrage de vaillant et c'est le
drame le plus monstrueux de l'année
l'eau du lac passe par-dessus le barrage
des millions de mètres cubes d'eau dans
une vague gigantesque se déverse à
travers la plaine détruisant la petite
ville de longaron et effaçant de la
carte h autres
villages seul le clocher de pirago
émerge de la destruction générale hommes
femmes enfin ont été sur pris dans leur
sommeil par le
[Musique]
cataclysme il faut déblayer mais les
efforts des équipes de secours et des
2000 soldats envoyés sur les lieux
semblent dérisoires en face d'une telle
dévastation que reste-t-il des village
d'hier
rien il semble qu'à part quelques ruines
tout soit
englouti peu de blessés et peu de
survivants 4000 morts dont la moitié à
peine ont été retrouvés et des pauvres
gens tout à coup sans famille et sans
foyer c'est longaron un nom qui ne
désigne plus rien qu'un
[Musique]
drame en Kabilie l'épreuve de force n'a
pas eu lieu on avait pu la craindre
quand l'ordre avait été donné à l'Armée
nationale populaire de faire mouvement
vers les centres tenus par les rebelles
mais l'affrontement lorsqu'il s'est
produit est toujours resté Pacifique
dissident d'un côté troupe régulière de
l'autre en définitive les premiers
cédèrent la place au second après
quelques palabres qui n'exclurent pas
par endroit certaines formes de
fraternisation
provisoire à Michelet les deux leaders
donnèrent l'exemple aamed et le colonel
moaneladj optèrent pour le départ sans
effusion de avant l'arrivée des chars et
des soldats de l'ANP Michelet comme
toutes les villes de kabili fut ainsi
occupé sans coup
[Musique]
faerire quant aux rebelles ils ont pris
avec leur chef le chemin du
Maqui pour nous a pu dire ben Bella
l'affaire kabil est réglée
mais ils restent les irréductibles de la
[Musique]
montagne c'est dans le Jura que se sont
déroulé cette année les grandes
manœuvres d'automne de l'armée française
manœuvre dont le déroulement suivi par
le ministre des Armées monsieur Mesmer
visait à expérimenter les armes
actuelles dans l'opposition d'un parti
rouge et d'un parti bleu épaulé cette
fois par la défense opérationnelle du
territoire le général de Gaul venu
assister aux phases final a vu ainsi
pousser à l'horizon les champignons
fictifs qui précédaient la
contreoffensive des chars AMX capable
d'évoluer en milieu partiellement
radioactif ces manœuvres inhabituelles
se sont achevé de la manière la plus
classique à besinçon le chef de l'État a
présidé le défilé auquel prenait part
hélicoptère avion de transport chasseur
à réaction ainsi que plusieurs centaines
de blindés qui suivaient les troupes à
pied
[Musique]
editth Piaf est
morte notre reporter l'avait surprise il
y a peu de temps à l'un de ces moments
où renaissante après une crise de la
maladie qui vient cette fois de
l'emporter et qui la terrassa plusieurs
fois déjà elle faisait de nouveaux
projets et souriait une nouvelle fois à
la vie je vais bientôt rechanter dans 3
semaines puisque chanter c'est ma vie je
ne peux pas m'empêcher de chanter et je
rechanterai très vite pour vous j'ai
payé de tant de
larmes pour
toujours le droit
d'aimer pour
d'aimer
[Musique]
la maladie a été la plus forte et tous
les grands noms de la chanson française
d'ive Montan à Tino Rossi et à Gilbert
becco sont venus apporter leur hommage à
cette voix inoubliable qui restera comme
un écho de notre époque et c'est
pourquoi la foule de Paris pendant des
heures a défilé devant son cercueil
comme devant une amie très bonne et très
aimée quelques heures après dans son
village de Mii la forêt céignet touché
au cœur peut-être par la mort d'édit
Piaf celui qui fut l'enfant terrible de
la littérature d'une époque et l'esprit
le plus brillant d'une génération Jean
cocto celui à qui à 22 ans diagilev
avait dit étonne-moi et qui pendant 50
ans étonna le monde poème ou dessin
théâtre ou cinéma il toucha à tout
toucha tout de génie passant de
l'illustration de ses livres à la
décoration d'une chapelle passant des
mariés de la tour effffelle aux enfants
terribles et de l'éternel retour au sang
d'un poète à l'avant-garde des lettre il
n'en fut pas moins l'élu de la tradition
lorsqu'il entra à l'Académie française
il ne rapportait que 8 ans laabiver mais
il possédait déjà son immortalité le
tout Paris des Arts et des Lettres le
cinéma avec René clairec la scène avec
Brial et Jean Naret sont venus saluer la
silhouette frê usée par la maladie
qu'avait animé l'esprit le plus
étincelant
il reste son œuvre et c'est une partie
de cette œuvre au 1000 facettes qui
survivra tout près de sa maison à
sablesse des simples dans cette chapelle
où à l'ombre des formes qu'il a créé
reposera le poète Jean
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coctau commencé voici quelques semaines
l'offensive contre la hausse des prix
est aujourd'hui engagée sur tous les
fronts dans 100000 points de vente on
peut suivre le jeu des baisses consentis
par les organisations professionnelles
ou organisé grâce à l'effort des
magasins
pilotes si le secteur de la viande
demeure le point névralgique de la
campagne il semble que sur les autres
produits la décision penche du bon côté
pour le savoir notre reporter a
interrogé au hasard quelques-uns de ces
gens qui sont comme la plupart d'entre
nous du côté du panier de laaménagère
faire votre marché qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette opération stabilité des
prix 100000 points de vente et bien
Monsieur J'ai constater que sur certains
articles dans certains magasins par il y
a certainement eu un effort de baisse je
trouve que ici c'est encore ils ont
gardé leur prix mais les bouchés par
exemple ça c'est c'est affreux mais je
pense que c'est très bien je pense que
ça va continuer on s'aperçoit quand même
qu'il y a un ttinet de baisse quand même
pas tout à fait très très sensible enfin
parce que le gouvernement a raison de
d'appliquer ces méthodes mais et quelle
stabilité des prix jusqu'à présent je me
suis pas encore vraiment rendu compte si
c'est il faut faire une économie sur un
marché de 5 ou 10 francs pour moi c'est
encore rien c'est très bien monsieur je
trouve ça très bien ça diminue un peu le
budget vous savez pour les question des
gens qui sont une paye assez difficile
je trouve que c'est très bien oui et
vous avez constaté une baisse
intéressante sur certains produits mais
oui monsieur parfaitement dur s encore à
l'instant et bien mettons sur les pâtes
sur l'huile la semaine dernière c'était
le chocolat cette semaine ce sont les
gâteaux puis enfin il y a la salade tout
ça ça suit bien moi je trouve que il
faut faire un effort de ce côté-là
continuer l'effort actuellement vous
voyez quand même une stabilité dans les
prix les ou je crois qu' je crois
qu'elle est forcé mais insiste sur le
biftech la campagne de stabilisation
encore à son début doit créer un
équilibre stable entre le panier et le
[Musique]
porte-monnaie les Parisiens attendaient
un miracle de Ray Suger Robinson culote
blanche le plus grand boxeur de
l'après-gerre ils avaient oublié que Ray
Suger a 43 ans Robin
cach son par coquie il ne peut plus
faire illusion sur un
r il a pourtant toujours grand allure il
est très bel athlète mais cela ne suffit
pas pour vaincre sans discussion un
adversaire au reste van qui lui est
opposé fait mieux que de se défendre et
pourtant vanuc n'est pas un
[Applaudissements]
superman le combat va jusqu'à la limite
sans donner cependant le grand frisson
au
spectateurs
finalement victoire au point pour
Robinson une victoire un peu tirée par
les cheveux qui n'a convaincu
[Applaudissements]
personne les leaders du championnat de
France de football les Toulousains
maillon froncé culotte blanche peuvent
dire aujourd'hui qu'ils reviennent de
loin après leur match du Parc des
Princes contre le Racing Club de Paris
le match nul qu'ils ont obtenu est
extrêmement flatteur pour eux première
mi-temps assez équilibré malgré quelques
occasion de but pour le Racing comme
celle-ci gâché par mag deè mi-temps les
Parisiens prennent avantage 1 à
0 et puis plus rien le Racing se
recroqueeville un peu trop Toulouse bien
timidement cependant en profite pour
relancer ses
attaques les 30000 spectateurs croient à
la victoire du Racing lorsqu'à 2 minutes
de la fin du match se produit un coup de
théâtre penalty pour Toulouse d'ailleurs
très justifié by le tir à côté le goal
parisien a plongé trop tôt dit l'arbitre
il faut tirer une nouvelle fois le
penalty mais personne n'est d'accord
avec lui Toulouse profite de l'occasion
match nul un match nul tiré par les
cheveux et qui provoque une belle
tempête dans les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tribunes le général de Gaulle sera dans
l'histoire le premier chef d'État
français à avoir rendu visite à
l'Iran le chat et l'impératrice faradiba
ont accueilli le président et l'ont
conduit au palais du Golestan dans la
salle des diamants où avait lieu un
dîner d'appara à l'issue de ce dîner le
général de Gaulle devait déclarer
de peuples libres la liberté paraî
d'autant plus précieuse qu'elle se
trouve actuellement menacée il y a là un
lien puissant et
permanent entre les entretiens
politiques tourisme et curiosité trouv
leur place c'est ainsi que derrière
d'énormes portes d'acier le souverain
fit découvrir à seses le trésor FÉRIQUE
des nuit du trône des P au couronnes
impériales et à ce globe terrestre où
chaque capitale est un
diamant
puis ce fut percé police la métropole
construite par Darius et détruite par
Alexandre dont les ruines monumentales
étonnent
toujours et hispant la ville des Roses
et là comme à Chiraz devant
l'enthousiasme des foule le général de
Gaulle a pu mesurer la porte voyage qui
marquait après une absence de plusieurs
années le retour de la France dans le
[Applaudissements]
Moyen-Orient diverses manifestation ont
salué le départ du chancelier adonoer à
Hanovre d'abord ce fut la revue de cette
bundosphère créée par adonoer en
1954 puis à bonne le Parlement a pris
congé de celui qui porta pendant 14 ans
le destin de l'Allemagne et qui lui
restitua sa place dans le cercle des
grandes
nations herart lui succède herart qui
fut son ministre de l'économie et qui
fit d'une Allemagne ruinée une Allemagne
en pleine
[Musique]
prospérité le chef du gouvernement
anglais Monsieur M Milan a quitté le
pouvoir qu'il détenait depuis
1957 sur son conseil la reine
elliisabeth a choisi pour lui succéder à
Downing Street le ministre des Affaires
étrangères Lord hum qui devra renoncer à
son titre pour rentrer à la Chambre des
communes Premier ministre et chef du
Parti conservateur sœur Alexandre dou
se trouve devant des problèmes
[Musique]
difficiles au milieu des sables rien ne
marque la frontière au confin
algéro-marocain mais pour cette ligne
sans vrai dessin algérien et marocains
s'affrontent deux postes perdus dans le
désert assiibida et tinjub ont été
l'enjeu d'une lutte sévère occupée tour
à tour par les deux
adversaires finalement les forces
marocaines ont repris ces deux positions
avec leurs point d'eau et leurs
palmerais la rencontre avait fait une
dizaine de morts et des
blessés à Marrakech Monsieur Mohamed
Yazid venu au nom du président Ben Bella
s'entretenir avec le roi du Maroc de ce
douloureux problème reprenait sans être
arrivé à un accord le chemin d'Alger
d'Alger ou devant une foule survoltée
réunie sur le forum le président Ben
Bella appelait au arme le peuple
algérien et décrétait la mobilisation de
tous les anciens
junud pendant ce temps à Marrakech le
roi Hassan 2 recevait la visite d' Negus
aess et lacier au cours de cette visite
prévue depuis longtemps mais dont les
circonstances allaient changer le sens
le Négus allait en effet chercher à
faire avancer le dialogue
algéro-marocain vers une solution de
paix partout en Algérie la mobilisation
s'opérait les anciens junud répondant à
l'appel de Ben Bella reprenait du
service et sur la route de colombéchard
Centre de rassemblement des forces
algériennes les renforts commençaient à
monter vers cette frontière imprécise
qui n'est peut-être qu'un prétexte pour
lequel s'affrontent deux idées
politiques et deux façons de concevoir
l'avenir du
Magreb les besoins domestiques comme
ceux de l'industrie imposent à la
production électrique de doubler tous
les 10 ans en effet la France consommait
en 52 41 milliards de kWh elle en a
consommé 83 en
1962 et c'est une véritable course
contre la montre que traduit la carte de
France de l'équipement en 10 ans barrag
et central thermique ont dû constamment
précéder une demande sans cesse
grandissante le survol de la seule
vallée du Drac dans les Alpes est à ce
titre éloquant depuis 1930 où fut édifié
le barrage du saut cette vallée n'a
cessa de se hérisser d'ouvragees
nouveaux aux installations de Cordéac
ont succédé celle d'un troè barrage
celui de Saint-Pierre cet enfin un 4è
est entré en service le plus important
mon la retenue de 240 millions de mè CB
autorisera une production totale de 430
million de kWh he lorsque deux nouveaux
groupes seront ajoutés au deux groupes
déjà en
service la centrale thermique de ver
dans la région parisienne illustre un
autre aspect de cette progression qui
exige des usines de plus en plus
puissantes
vert du reste détient un record européen
avec un groupe de 250000 kW à une seule
ligne d'arbre 41 milliard de kWh en 1952
83 en 1962 et l'électricité de France se
prépare à en produire 170 milliards en
[Musique]
1972 c'est seulement maintenant que l'on
peut se faire une idée de la violence de
de cet ouragan auquel les
météorologistes donnèrent le nom de
Flora de Cuba nous parviennent les
images dramatiques de ces journées qui
virent disparaître des milliers
d'habitations anéantir des milliers
d'hectares de plantations et provoquer
plus de 1000
morts pendant 5 jours le vent et la
pluie se sont acharnés sur
l'île l'eau inexorablement s'est répandu
sur les terres basses s'étalant comme
dans la province d'Oriente sur un front
de 40 à 80 km
Fidel Castro s'est mis à la tête des
secours organisant lui-même les convois
de sauvetage c'est d'ailleurs au cours
d'une de ses missions que son véhicule
amphibie faillit sombrer en traversant
le cours tumultueux de la rivière
[Musique]
lariora partout le même spectacle
tragique camion jetés par le flot hors
de la route et sur lesquels se sont
réfugiés des groupes surpris par
l'inondation plantation hier florissante
aujourd'hui couverte par un flot boueux
les hélicoptères ont été lancés à la
recherche des rescapés repérant les
groupes en détresse et secourant les
isolés car sur cet immense désert
liquide des hommes vivent encore au pris
avec la faim la soif et la
peur
Cuba offre le spectacle d'un immense
désastre culture submergé troupeau
foudroyés dans leur fuite maisons
effondré communication
coupé 1000 mors et 100 s abris et il
faut le ajouter les victimes d'Haïti de
la Martinique de la Jamaïque celle de
toutes ces Antilles ravagé par l'ouragan
Flora des milliers de morts et des
milliers de pauvres gens jetés soudain
au cœur du malheur des visages creusés
par une aventure humaine et à qui il ne
reste plus vraiment plus que leurs yeux
pour
[Applaudissements]
pleurer
assiibida reste le point névralgique du
conflit algéro-marocain le point d'eau
et la minuscule palmerais sont occupés
par l'armée royale marocaine qui sous le
commandement du général Dris affirme
avoir nettoyer la région des éléments
algériens les Marocains ont fait
prisonnier quatre officiers égyptiens
intervention égyptienne d' rabat simple
mission d'assistance technique répond
Alger mais à la suite de tels incidents
le ton a monté au Maroc dans les rues de
la Mdina de Marrakech une foule a
manifesté contre Ben Bella à l'heure où
le roi Hassan déclarait le Maroc n'est
pas l'agresseur il est certain de son
bon droit ces paroles ont naturellement
trouvé un écho dans la population qui a
fait de Marrakech à Mogador un triomphe
à son souverain en écho et dans tous les
villages berbères de nombreux supplétifs
s'armment pour combattre des formations
de Tabor vont aller appuyer l'armée
royale en action au frontières du
désert pant le néus lacier continuait
après de Ben Bella ses efforts de
médiation effort qui allit aboutir à
l'ouverture d'une conférence à
bamaco cependant Alger envoyait de
nouveaux renforts vers la ligne des
combats armement accéléré de nouvelles
unités convois d'armes dirigé d'urgence
sur les pistes du Sud c'était la guerre
qui continuait
[Musique]
car là-bas dans les sables la canonade
raisonnait
toujours canonade qui bientôt on
l'espère s'arrêtera sur une décision
venue de
[Musique]
bamaco conce supersonique
franco-britannique n'est plus un rêve on
peut dès aujourd'hui effectuer un vol
immobile à bord de cet avion
révolutionnaire grâce aux éléments d'une
maquette grandeur nature par ailleurs
les problèmes particuliers que posait le
vol à Mac 2 d'un tel appareil ont été
étudiés dans les soufleries françaises
comme dans les soufleries Britanniques
la première maquette de travail a main
de fois passé le mur du
[Musique]
son
elle a vogé à la vitesse de croisière
plus de deux fois la vitesse du son qui
sera celle des passagers de demain à
17000 m d'altitude sous la poussée des 4
turboréacteurs à colombéchard emporté
par un missile D6 elle a été soumise aux
conditions réell d'échauffement des vols
supersonique tous les renseignements
concernant les températures ont été
communiqués par
télémesure de cause on a pu ainsi
éprouver la résistance du métal un
aluminium spécial en soumettant un
élément d'Ile aux effets puissants de
radiateur à infrarouge rendez-vous avec
les 100 premiers passagers en 1968 pour
le vol inaugural Paris New York en
[Musique]
3h au Cercle interalié Catherine Langel
docteur vach Roméo Carles Robert Roca
ont décerné à la palme du roman
d'espionnage ou plus exactement les
palmes d'or puisque la récompense
consiste en une médaille d'or de taille
très honorable frappée par les atelier
de la monnaie minourouet qui a depuis
longtemps abandonné la conttesse de
Ségure fut une des premières à faire
signé par l'auteur son exemplaire du
roman primé le carnaval des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vautou voici 30 ans un coiffeur de
Tarascon monsieur bonour devenait
célèbre du jour au lendemain c'était le
premier gagnant du gros lot de la lrina
tion c'est donc ces 30 ans d'existence
que fait la Loterie nationale par une
tranche spéciale 30 ans pendant
lesquelles les sphères ont fait d'autres
bonour 30 ans pendant lesquels chaque
semaine on a vu de ses gagnants
encaisser des gros lots mais le curieux
c'est que très peu sont connu difficile
de localiser un de ces heureux mortels
pour lesquels l'anonymat a plus de
charme que la gloire essayez donc de
confesser le voisin qui apparaî un
bonjour au valant d'une belle voiture
neuve monsieur s'il vous plaît je
m'excuse une question avait fait fortune
je pour savoir
rien il a gagné la lo nationale bonour
avait claironné sa chance ses
successeurs presque à l'unanimité ont
gardé un visage fermé comme un coffre
fort modestie ou prudence pourtant
pendant ces 30 ans on a vu des livrets
de Caisse d'Épargne se gonfler d'un seul
coup jusqu'au maximum la
loterie pourtant des couples hier sans
espérance ont soudain acquis la maison
de leur rêves la
loterie pourtant des familles sans
moyens se sont offert une belle voiture
la loterie monsur monsieur monieur
avez-vous déjà gagné un gros lot à la
loterie nationale jamais de la vie j'ai
pas de chance pas chance Jama pas non
madame madamevezv déjà gagné un et c'est
ainsi depuis 30 ans 30 ans qui ont vu
pourtant distribuer des tonnes d'or à
beaucoup de petits malin qui joue les
[Musique]
innocents
Louis lourmet c'est le champion des
hommes poissons mais c'est aussi un
monsieur qui veut la paix dans son
ménage sa femme Lilia lourmet était
championne du monde de survie dans l'eau
pour conserver sa dignité il a voulu
faire mieux qu'elle c'est-à-dire rester
plus de 30 heures au fond d'un aquarium
cet aquarium a été installé dans un
grand magasin parisien et c'est là
devant le public que Louis lourmet a
voulu prouver que l'homme est toujours
plus fort que sa femme comme il trouvait
le temps long il s'est payé un peu de
lecture et pour se nourrir il a utilisé
une petite poire bourrée de viande
hachée chaque jour il a pu avaler ainsi
de à 3 kg de bœuf ou de cheval cru
pendant les heures creuses à l'heure de
la fermeture du magasin Louis lourmet a
tué le temps comme il a
pu et pour meubler sa solitude il avait
un petit compagnon bien gentil et pas
très farouche ce petit poisson mais
après des heures et des heures sous
l'eau la fatigué d' Louis lourmain y
voyait plus
guerre enfin recordbat 31h sous l'eau
Liliane lourmet est sans rancune c'est
elle qui annonce la bonne
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle et que croyez-vous qu'a fait
lourmet après sa performance pour se
reposer il est allé prendre un bain
chasser le
[Musique]
naturel on a fêté à Rome l'anniversaire
de la
police le président SNI a présidé cette
manifestation à laquelle ont participé
les Anges de la route 170 motards de la
police ont en effet effectué des
exhibitions particulièrement
spectaculaire et
[Musique]
audacieuse ces remarquables balai
motorisés ont entousiasm tous ceux qui
ont assisté aux cérémonie anniversaire
de la police
[Musique]
italienne
il a suffi d'un seul match à l'équipe de
France de football maillot foncé culotte
clair pour se faire pardonner par son
public du Parc des Princes plusieurs
saisons particulièrement désastreuse il
est vrai que pour cette équipe de France
face à la Bulgarie c'était le match de
la dernière chance une espèce de kitou
double où se jouait le prestige du
Football
France les Bulgares n'en sont pas encore
revenus ils ont trouvé en face d'eux une
équipe transfigurée rapide incisive et
même
efficace sous la baguette magique de
dwis numéro 10 en prière mi-temps les
Français ont donné une idée très
flatteuse de leur football ponctué par
un très joli but de
Boujon 2è mi-temps plus laborieuse après
l'éclatante démonstration des 45
premières minutes à peine les Français
prennent-ils le temps de souffler un peu
que les Bulgares en profitent pour
égaliser c'est la consternation dans les
tribunes et du côté du banc du
sélectionneur il joue une grosse partie
après le lâchage inadmissible de Raymond
Copa il avait tort d'être inquiet en un
quart d'heure l'équipe de France reprend
l'avantage et lâche irrésistiblement les
Bulgares d'abord par Robert herb numéro
8 l'homme de la 2è mi-temps qui domine
partenaire et adversaire de la tête et
des
épaaues et puis par goujon qui va
ajouter un 3oè but de la tête but qui
qualifie la France pour les quarts de
finale de la Coupe d'Europe des
nations cette victoire de l'équipe de
France revalorise singulièrement le
football français qui est peut-être
parti du bon pied l'équipe de France
trouve en tout cas qu'elle n'a sans
doute pas besoin de r mon Copa et qu'il
a eu tort de dire non au
[Musique]
sélectionneur